so hello and welcome to yet another
episode of biographics I'm your interim
host Carl Smallwood that's Carl with a K
Ka a r l not s i m o n because I've seen
people mispronouncing it and misspelling
it that way which is very strange anyway
with that out the way today we're
talking about a menp the Magnificent the
Pinnacle of Egyptian prosperity and as
with all the videos here on biographics
this one is based on original script
submitted To Us by a member of our
writing team that member today being Ru
Alexander you can follow them on the
social media links below if you are so
inclined mine are also down there as are
the things you can press that make you
know the Channel's numbers go up which
means I get paid more money you know
like comment subscribe all that good
stuff and one final bit of housekeeping
before we get into the video itself this
video contains a lot of words I was
unfamiliar with so I did look up
pronunciation guides on things like and
then hat or other ancient Egyptian kings
and Pharaohs and one thing that made me
kind of uncomfortable while I was doing
that is I stumbled across an old
documentary narrated by a stuffy British
man
um about the Valley of the Kings and
during that they have footage of stuff
that's in the Egyptian Museum which the
stuffy British narrator refers to as our
culture yeah we sure do suck
anyway today we are traveling back to
the 14th century BC to the New Kingdom
of Egypt during the time of the 18th
Dynasty this dynasty is a world we had
gone to before numerous times it's
arguably produced the greatest number of
notable rumors from that period several
already featured here at biographics
with our old host Simon not Carl Simon
we're different people you see there's
haep SZ the queen of the Pharaoh there's
Moos III one of the greatest conquerers
that Egypt had ever seen and there's the
heretic who cast aside the old gods and
worship Aton and of course there's the
boy King himself Tuton Caron and then
there's also the subject for today am
menap he was the father of the
forementioned heretic and tot's
grandfather Maybe but he was also the
pharaoh who brought his kingdom to an
unparalleled Apex of international power
arguably creating the most prosperous
period in Egypt's entire history and
thus rightfully earn the Monica of am
menp the Magnificent but we can't start
there we have to start as we often like
to do at the beginning
with the menet which literally
translates to Ammon is content was born
sometime around 1400 BC to Thutmose the
four and one of his secondary wives mam
we depending on the exact year of his
birth his father might not have become
Pharaoh yet and was just the Crown
Prince at the time while the actual
ruling monar was his grandfather and his
Nam sake amen II however years later
when he actually became Pharaoh am man
was proclaimed to be the son of none
other than amund the king of the Gods
who took the form of thos and impregnate
his mother inscriptions at the Temple of
luar say this about their romantic
encounter she awoke on the account of
the Aroma of the god and cried out
before him he went to her straight away
she rejoiced at the sight of his Beauty
and love for him C through her body the
palace was flooded with God's Aroma I'm
just going to let that sit and let
everyone at home figure out what God's
Aroma is and what his love was cing
through her means words spoken by amund
am R of Thieves is the name of the child
I have placed in your body he shall
exercise the benefit kingship in this
whole land he shall rule the two lands
like raah for ever so yeah having your
dad be the king of the Gods was pretty
handy for a menap he had a relatively
relaxed childhood spent mostly around
the family Palace in a little place
called gurob whose ruins lie near modern
city of fume he was mainly looked after
by the king's Treasurer sobec hotep hail
sobec and had been appointed his
Guardian meanwhile his father was away
on Military matters making sure that
Egypt maintained its new found Regional
dominance by getting into a few scuffles
with some of its neighbors such as
matani and Nubia originally amen wasn't
meant to become Pharaoh that honor was
was supposed to go to th M's eldest son
amen hat but he died so young that amen
was called up to the plate and then thos
himself cashed in his chips in the 10th
year of his Reign and am menet was
crowned the new Pharaoh cira 1391 BC now
most sources seem to agree that he was
around 12 years old at this time so it's
highly likely that he had a regent who
ruled in instead although their name was
lost to history soon after taking the
throne the boy King got married to his
great Royal wife TI over the years am
men would take many many other wives
most of them princesses from nearby
kingdoms but his relationship with ta
seem to have been truly special maybe
even unique among the Pharaohs of Egypt
for starters there did not appear to be
any political motivations behind the
union sure ta's parents yuu and fuya
were wealthy officials and landowners
but they were not even of Royal Blood
despite this the men had showed them
both great care and respect and not only
gave them both high ranking positions in
his court but even had them both buried
in a tomb in the Valley of the Kings and
then of course there's ta herself no
other queen in Egyptian history as ever
figured so prominently into her
husband's life there are tons of
surviving reliefs inscriptions in tombs
and temples and jewelry and Ceramics
where her name is featured right there
alongside her husbands she was also
often depicted with elements of the
goddess hathor and sometimes even
represented as a sphinx which was
typically only a thing for Pharaohs then
there statues where amenhotep and TI
were shown together and are of equal
size which again was not how things were
normally done back in ancient Egypt the
Pharaoh was always supposed to be bigger
and grander than everybody else he was
depicted alongside and it seems that a
menen had adopted an egalitarian
approach that had never been seen before
in Egyptian Society up till
then and Men did not waste a lot of time
once all the traditional duties and
ceremonies for the burial of his father
were complete he got down to work
although to be fair he had been handed
quite a cushy gig when am menh had set
became Pharaoh his kingdom was rich the
Harvest were Bountiful and most
importantly of all it was peaceful in
fact throughout this entire Reign which
lasted almost four decades a rarity for
an Egyptian pharaoh am men only had to
take part in one military campaign that
we're aware of in his fifth regnal year
he traveled to Kush where he conquered
an alliance of rebelling tribes and took
30,000 prisoners most of the time he
refer to use diplomacy especially by
just marrying the daughters of
neighboring Kings or by using his wealth
to Simply buy the Loyalty of those
around him both very effective
techniques because he did not have to
concentrate his time and resources on
war a menm could focus on the thing he
really cared about building lots and
lots of stuff he's widely considered one
of the most prolific Builders of ancient
Egypt with no other pharaoh leaving
behind more tangible proof of his or her
existence with a possible exception of
Ramsey's the great in fact Ramsey's
cheated to get top marks because some of
his Works were actually made by am menp
Ramsey's just crossed out his
predecessor's name and replaced it with
his own which was a pretty cheeky thing
to do but was relatively common among
the Pharaohs in order to build you are
going to need materials which is why
amen's first major action as Pharaoh was
to open several new Limestone quaries
and reopen a few older ones that have
been abandoned a long time ago with a
steady supply of stone on its way the
Pharaoh began work on one of the
multiple ambitious projects that would
consume the greatest part of his Reign
carak carak was a large Temple complex
built in thieves near modern day city of
luxa construction of it been taking
place since the Middle Kingdom of
ancient Egypt around the 20th century BC
and its importance to Egyptian culture
grew steadily with the rise of Thieves
as a city served as the capital for a
lot of the second half of ancient
Egypt's history usually splitting this
Duty with Memphis Pharaohs were always
adding new stuff to carak usually stuff
that said how amazing and awesome they
were although to give credit to a men
the first thing he did at carak was
finish the shrine that his father was
building when he died after that a menm
oversaw extensive refurbishing and
Renovations of a temple complex that
took decades to complete some areas he
redesigned completely and the others had
older structures removed and recycled
for his own building projects like he
literally took other buildings ground
them down and then built new buildings
out of them never say the Egyptians
weren't an industrious people his own
greatest contribution to KAC was a 10th
pylon meaning a Monumental gateway to a
temple which adorned with two giant
statues of himself what a baller it said
that amen absolutely loved seeing
himself in Statue form and who really
knows how many he had commissioned
during his lifetime but he holds the
record for and I quote the faroh with
the most surviving statues with
approximately 250 to his name that
depict a steady progression of the
manet's life from his childhood all the
way to old age or at least old age in
like ancient Egyptian standards he lived
to about 50 years old and it's not just
buildings that am menp had a thing for
he also had a weird obsession with
scarabs and while many other pharaohs
prefer to inscribe their achievements on
Temple walls or stone monuments am men
like to write on scarabs and since his
Reign hundreds of these things have been
found inscribed on their undersiz to let
the world know what a menp had been up
to each one was sort of like a mini
diary only on a Scarab and not a big
stone plate as would be common back then
for for example there are over 120
surviving scarabs that just talk about
the pharaoh's first decade on the throne
and they all mention just how great of a
hunter and Men attack was and that he
killed a reported 102 Lions during one
of his hunts there's also a sweeter less
lion murder orientated example of a
dozen ass so scarabs that describe how a
men had gifted his wife an entire Lake
in her hometown during his 11th regnar
year and then took her on a boat ride on
it and if you're wondering how a menet
gifted his wife a lake surely the lake
was just there no no he had a lake built
named it after her and then took her a
ride upon it but you know what let's
just quote the scarabs shall we his
majesty commanded the making of a lake
for his great Royal wife Tia long may
she live in her hometown it length for
3,700 cubits and its width of 700 cubits
his majesty celebrated the Festival of
opening on the lake in the third month
of inundation day 16 his majesty was Rod
in the Royal barge the dazzling sun
[Music]
disk
so enough scarabs for now let's get back
to the bigger stuff back in thieves on
the East Bank of the nil River besides
carak there was another Temple complex
called Lua nowadays there's pretty much
one a and one b in terms of importance
but in a manhep day Lua was still a
little wet behind the ears shall we say
we don't know for sure when it was first
built but the oldest Shrine at the
complex dates back to the afor mantion
haet suit less than a century before am
menet became Pharaoh he was the one who
built the core of the temple as well as
the great corn a made up of two rows of
colossal columns and the birth room
which tells the story of how amra was
the true father of the menap over the
centuries other pharaohs made their own
additions to the temple complexes such
as to and Kon and most notably Ramsey II
and even the Romans got in on it at some
point building a fort around the temple
during their own era and when amen felt
that there wasn't enough room anymore at
carak and looks saw for all the things
he wanted to build he said screw it and
just traveled to the middle of a desert
to construct an entirely new complex
there as well originally called per high
or the house of rejoicing it was later
known as malcata and became the
pharaoh's permanent residence once the
Royal Palace was completed but besides
the palace malcata had halls with giant
decorated columns luxurious apartments
and Villas workshops store rooms
administrative officers a workers
Village and of course lots and lots of
temples and statues so in truth it was
more of a small city than a religious
complex however it was abandoned almost
immediately after amenhotep's death and
quickly went to ruin and finally we
arrive at the main event the pharaoh's
most or inspiring Construction the Mory
Temple of am men III this was the
grandest structure of its kind ever
built in ancient Egypt and it was known
quite fittingly as the Mansion of
millions of years well befitting of a
ruler such as a menh now you might be
thinking to yourself why a Mory Temple
and not a pyramid right that's the thing
Egyptians are known for like the
triangles right the tringle what what
gives well by the time of a menet giant
pyramids were kind of old hats and they'
gone out of style by the time of the
men's Reign and while yes theid Middle
Kingdom did sometimes bury its pharaohs
in pyramids these were definitely built
on a budget and lacks shall we say the
Grandeur of the pyramids we see at Giza
by the time of the New Kingdom though
the Pharaohs prefer to be buried inside
Rock Cut tombs in the Valley of the
Kings on the West Bank of the Nile and
having a big fancy Mory Temple where
people could come and worship them for
centuries after they died had become the
new trend bring it back to amen he
certainly not skimp on his own Mory
Temple the first thing that people saw
as they approached the complex was the
colosi of mnan two giant statues Seated
on Thrones each one six sories tall and
weighing some 720 tons that guarded the
entrance to the temple the structure
itself was around 600 M long and 100 m
wide and contained hundreds of statues
sphinxes and reliefs that detailed the
life and accomplishments of the Pharaoh
visitors had to enter through three
pylons then Traverse a long Corridor
that led to an open Solar Courtyard a
sanctuary roofed Hall and multiple alts
and this would have likely been a
jaw-dropping sight to behold but
unfortunately amen made one key mistake
when building his Temple he placed it
too close to the Nile and over the
centuries it was subject to frequent
floodings one big earthquake in 27 BC
and the typical plunderings and
recyclings of materials by his immediate
successors today the temple lies largely
in Ruins and the only thing really left
standing are the two colosi of mnon who
are still fulfilling their duty of
guarding the entrance even after 3,000
years but it's not all bad because
modern excavations have Unearthed
artifacts and statues that have been
buried under tons of soils for literal
Millennia so who knows what else they
might find in the near future was buried
beneath the
sand as we know would be pretty obvious
by now amen's reputation as a great
Builder was well deserved as it was
truly his L on detr but being a pharaoh
can't be all temples and scarabs as cool
as that would be you know you still have
a kingdom to run what well you know
you're building your temples and carving
your wife's name on your scarabs but was
mentioned previously when a manent was
given the keys to a throne and the
executive bathroom Egypt was sitting
pretty as the dominant Regional power
nobody was really looking to challenge
the state as quot okay so the Hittites
were recurring thorn in Egypt's side but
they too were preoccupied with all
things during aep's Reign and it wasn't
until a few decades later there would
become a serious danger but all the
other kings in the area were more likely
to write to EMP looking for a handout or
marriage Alliance than to start some
trouble possibly the first to do so was
king shutan of a second matani who
married his daughter and I hope I
pronounce this correctly kilpper to am
menp and was followed by Bab on and hour
hour and possibly other kings we don't
know about what we do know is that these
alliances through marriage were strictly
a one-way Street as revealed in the AM
letters that recorded correspondence
between the Egyptian pharaohs and their
Royal neighbors for example letters four
and five real discussion between am menp
and the Babylonian King at the time
where the Egyptian pharaoh requests a
wife but refuses to return the favor to
Babylon making it clear that and I quote
since time IM memorium no daughter of
the king of Egypt has ever been given in
marriage basically it was another sign
that a men had sent was sitting at the
head of the table and called all the
shots while all the other kings had no
choice but to just stand there smile
politely and let him you know have sex
with their daughters on the other hand
Egypt also had vast supplies of gold
during The menps Reign and the Pharaoh
often sent large amounts of gold as
gifts to the other rulers to soothe
their bruised Egos and by and large he
managed to keep everybody happy so yes
he just send like literal wagons load of
gold to the other kings so they wouldn't
know want to start anything but it
wasn't all smooth sailing for our boy am
menet because some time during 1365 BC
when he was approaching his Landmark
30th year on the throne the Pharaoh
suffered a terrible personal tragedy
when he lost his eldest son Crown Prince
thos just like his own father before him
it was pretty clear that am menp had
Grand Ambitions for his son and expected
that one day he would succeed him as the
Pharaoh th MOS was often depicted in
official inscriptions alongside his
father and was bestowed various
honorifics titles and honors and it's
worth noting that THM did have siblings
and they were rarely if ever mentioned
in such inscriptions especially not
alongside their illustrious father his
death was a shock straight to the heart
of the Pharaoh and to his people who by
that point had grown pretty accustomed
to A Reign defined by peace and
prosperity Not Tragedy furthermore
thought moses' death forced amep to name
his second son who he also called amep
as the new Crown Prince and we actually
do have a biographics video on amep Jun
you can go watch after this if you are
so inclined and a cliff notes version is
that amep Junior
was wasn't great wasn't very popular
King he uh well the first thing he did
is declared himself The Reincarnation of
the son God Aton changed his name from a
men attemp to Aken attan um he got rid
of the classic Egyptian Pantheon of cool
animal headed gods and instead declared
that was only one true like Mega God
Aton the a disc of sun which is way less
cool than like know Anubis and sobec and
all those other cool animal-headed Gods
but that's a story for another day let's
get back to amep senior shall we so
after he' named his new successor he did
not really have much time to grieve for
his favored son as he was getting ready
for a rare and Monumental event in the
reign of any Pharaoh his first said
Festival that said s the said Festival
was an important ceremony that
celebrated a Pharaoh's long and
continued Rule and aimed to renew his
strength and keep his reain going the
first such Jubilee was commemorated
after 30 years on the throne and all
subsequent ceremonies occurred every
three or four years thereafter this
meant that most pharaohs never got one
said Festival since they had to have
ruled for at least three decades and
instead had to settle for the promise of
and I quote millions of jubilees in the
afterlife amep celebrated three said
festivals but obviously the first was
the biggest and most important of the
bunch in fact it was one of the grandest
of all time and the Pharaoh spent an
obscene amount of money to erect temples
and statues all along the length of the
Nile as well as manufacture thousands of
pieces of jewelry and ornaments for his
ceremony which took place at malcata and
less than a year after his third said
Festival a men had the third died during
his 38th year as Pharaoh close to the
age of
50 now normally in a biographics video
when the person dies that's when the
video ends and I start my Spiel of hey
if you enjoyed the video why not leave a
like comment below with feedback or
suggestions and subscribe for more
content like this but when we talk about
a pharaoh them dying is not the end
because their dead body usually got up
to some cool stuff and amena is no
exception so yeah as you might expect
since amena took the trouble to build
the biggest and grandest Mory temple in
all the land he was buried in an equally
Grand tomb close to it in the valley of
Kings designated KV 22 it is in fact the
largest tomb in the West Valley and
might have been originally intended for
thos IV since his name appears on
several Foundation inscriptions however
amenit probably decided that he liked
the two more and laid claim to it since
you know his dad wasn't exactly in a
position to protest and as mentioned
previously as Pharaohs were all deemed
to be The Reincarnation of the same God
it technically belonged to him the tomb
was first spotted by Scholars all the
way back during Napoleon's Egyptian
Expedition unfortunately since it was
easy to find by archaeologist it was
also easy to find by lutters so the time
like modern man explored it the tomb had
been mostly cleaned out probably
thousands of years earlier the
sarcophagus was gone and the good news
was that amen attemp hadn't been insided
for quite a while you see alongside a
dozen alsoo other mummies he'd be moved
to kv35 during the reign of smendes the
founder of the 21st dasty kv35
originally the tomb of menp II at a menp
grandpa were discovered in 1898 by
French egyptologist Victor lorett who
likely had quite a shock when he entered
the tomb and found a dozen mummies
belonging to some of the most important
and famous figures of the New Kingdom
just sitting there not really doing much
he probably went out and bought a
lottery ticket immediately afterwards
because you just don't get fines like
that as an archaeologist and since then
we've used modern methods to study am
and tet's mummy discovered this
surprising truth that people back then
weren't all that healthy even if they
were supposedly The Reincarnation of a
God for example in his final years a
menet was notably overweight suffered
from arthritis and had really bad teeth
probably from all the honey and sugar
that he ate as you know a member of
royalty nowadays am menh is resting
inside the new national museum of
Egyptian civilization in Cairo although
reminders of his Landmark Reign can
still be found not only throughout Egypt
but the entire world thanks in part to
said Luthers and archaeologist just
taking stuff and moving it around to
other museums and I believe we do have a
video on the um the British museum over
on our sister Channel by Geographics
that I also hosted and spend most of the
run time just like this of
yeah yeah British people kind of suck
speaking of which if you'd like to
follow our author on social media you
can do so are the links found below Radu
Alexander and I'm sure they'd like to
hear they did a good job on this script
you can follow me if you are so inclined
and you can also like leave comments
below for feedback suggestions and just
ideas for future videos you can also
just ask where the previous host was if
that's your thing I'm sorry I I got
asked to do this gig and I said yes
because I worked behind the scenes 10
years ago and know the owners of the
site I'm sorry if I'm not doing a good
job I'm trying my best and I'll continue
to try my best in future videos which
you can see by subscribing for more like
this now I'm going to drink this God
awful coffee
[Music]
B